i thought we'd continue looking at
points and point clouds last time if you
recall we talked about the iterative
closest point algorithm and the idea was
we have a load of points we have a load
more points and what we want to do is
try and move them closer together and
align those two meshes i mean they're
not messages that point cloud um with a
view to maybe doing a 3d reconstruction
or something like this now this is
actually really really common right in
3d sure in you know in 3d modelling you
might do this
you might do it to reconstruct bunny
rabbits but you might also do this on a
street scene suppose you're a robot who
is going through a scene and you're
doing these periodic lidar scans
you've got to take what you just scanned
and put it up against the 3d that you've
already scanned in the previous frames
and you've got to do this really really
quickly because if you don't
you're going to get way laid by the 60
hertz
rate of your of your lidar scanner
what we're going to talk about today is
something called a kd tree or
k-dimensional tree and it's a neat
little data structure that allows you to
very quickly find what the closest point
is given you know possibly millions of
other points we're going to look at this
mostly for my poor brain in two
dimensions right but this could be three
four five dimensional
and it could be n dimensional or should
we say there are k dimensions it's like
k means didn't we do k means it's the
same kind of idea right we don't know
how many it's going to be until we
actually have to implement it um but
actually the algorithm is exactly the
same if you do it in multiple dimensions
just gets a little bit slower so i've
got some points here and what we're
going to pretend we're doing is trying
to find closest points to some arbitrary
points so suppose we pop down our finger
here what's the closest point well it's
this one and that's easy for me because
i can see the whole picture but there's
a question basically if you're writing a
computer program to do this
what's the best way of implementing this
algorithm right so i've got a point
let's say it's you know five five or
something like this all these points
have coordinates in x and y right so i
mean just to be clear this is x and this
is y and
maybe we have a list of these points in
memory so we could go okay so if a list
starts with this one
that's the distance we're looking at and
then we look at this one and that's the
distance is slightly closer so that's
now the near the next closest this one's
further away this one's further away but
this one's closer and we can go through
each of our points in turn and
eventually if we record the current
minimum distance
we'll find the nearest point but you can
imagine that for points more than this
this is going to be a problem really
really quickly right for thousands for
millions of points possibly billions of
points in a 3d scan this is not going to
work what we do is we arrange these
points in something called a data
structure that allows us to better index
and better search them right and there
are a few data structures for off top of
my head that you could do this with
octrees for example or something that we
could maybe look at another time but i
like the kd tree because i think it's
neat and i've actually used it a couple
of times in research to find closest
points to things so these are our points
and we're going to imagine that there
for now we're not moving about right
they're not moving about
these are reference points we want to
find the closest point to here or the
closest point to here or something like
this and we need to do that as quickly
as we can
so what we're going to do is we can
construct a data structure that
represents these points in a different
way to a list
so that when we actually want to search
through them it's much much much quicker
so what we're going to do is we're going
to split up our points into two groups
and then for each of those groups we're
going to split them into two more groups
and we're going to complete this process
until you know you can't split them up
anymore and then every time we have a
point we can very quickly whittle down
where we're going to go so suppose we
wanted to split up this point set if
you're looking at this point set here
where would you split it you know
intuitively well somewhere in the middle
across the middle right right splitting
it here didn't make any sense right
that's a waste of time because because
if you happen to be looking for this
point it's an absolute winner right but
if you're looking for any of your other
points it's hugely slow so yes binary
trees tend to split things in two so
that's what we're going to do all right
so i'm going to use my let's let's start
with my blue pen and so we're going to
pick a dimension let's split um across
the x dimension right and we're going to
choose the median points at a point in
the middle now i've left a little gap to
make my life easier and it's this one so
we're going to do is we're going to do a
split
up like this like this and we're going
to split the data in two now actually
what we're doing is we're constructing a
tree so you don't actually physically
draw these lines in so you imagine these
are stored in memory maybe this is point
a perhaps so what we're going to do is
create a tree where the the root node
is point a right and i'm going to sort
of do this and hope it works
now suppose you wanted to find what was
closest to this point
it's probably a safe bet that the place
to look is this side of a rather than
this side of a that's kind of where
we're going but let's take this process
a bit further let's split here now we've
got two dimensions to split and so a
nice convention would be to alternate
splitting so we split first in x and
then we sort of divide it into four by
splitting in y and then we do x again
and so on so let's do it i don't know
with this uh orange pen right i've sort
of got a strange mishmash of pens here
so we're going to split it roughly in
two so one two three four five six seven
there's seven points so bears this point
is roughly in the middle all right
and so we're going to split it here
like that and we're going to do the same
for this side so under three so we're
going to split it about here and they're
not split in exactly the same place so
the interesting thing about something
like a quad tree is that they divide
everything into two every time spatially
so you would always split it into
quarters and then eighths and sixteenths
and so on but in here we actually split
it on a point that exists so let's
continue this so this is b this is c
right and so we're going to have b as a
child
and we're going to have c
as a child here like this so we're
actually constructing a tree now of
course these have points associated with
them right so let's keep going
where would we split this well probably
in the middle so let's split this one
here
like this this one here we're going to
split here
is that right yes i think that's right
and then this one
and
this one
my lines are not really straight that's
not really how two dimensions works but
we won't dwell on it uh and then finally
we're going to split here so actually i
mean as an example i'm not going to draw
out the whole tree but you could imagine
that if this was point um
d that's right yeah it comes off to see
thanks sean um d e
so d and e are children from b so let's
move that around so d
and e
and so on right so that's fairly
straightforward right now we actually do
technically split again
but of course it's not going to be
hugely helpful because we've got no
further points
these are sort of leaf
nodes right so something like this and
so on
okay good right so suppose now we're
trying to find the closest point to this
tree
all right so we can start we know we
know what the root root is and we can
very quickly go a b
e whatever this one is sort of go go in
into our tree and search around because
there might be other points and stuff
but it's going to depend a little bit on
where we're trying to find something so
let's suppose i put a point in here all
right now
don't forget that
we can sort of see the top-down overview
of this but really the computer is just
seeing
this kind of extended tree structure
here so it has to start at the top it
can't just go oh it's this one right it
doesn't work that way but you'll see how
hopefully this is much much quicker than
trying to find the closest point giving
us a list of points
so the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to look at a which is our
route and we're going to say right we're
looking over here
what is the what is the best
side to look on right now hopefully
you've all said this one
so all we need to do is compare the x
coordinate of this
with the x coordinate of a and no then
we know which child to go to so in this
case it's going to be child b right if
we look at our tree
a would have an x coordinate and we
literally just say well this is this is
an x dimension we're looking at on this
on this level
so we want to go this way now this is
going to be a y comparison here and then
the next comparison and then a y
comparison as we go deeper into the tree
so let's look at b we probably don't
want to go that way so this is going to
be a smaller or bigger y depending on if
you're a mathematician or a computer
graphics person so we're going to go
this direction now we're looking at e
all right so e is a child of b
and so we want to be on this side so we
jump to this side and then we find
ourselves at this end point here right
so let's for the sake of argument let's
call this uh g right just so i can
name it so you might think well that's
good right we found the closest point
it's g now that's not actually true
because we've only looked at a b e and g
directly we've just gone down the tree
we haven't seen anything else so it's
possible for instance that there could
be a secret sneaky point the other side
of e that we're not considering or
another point you know over here or
something like this what we need to do
is go down the tree and then slowly work
our way back up the tree to make
absolutely sure there's no hidden points
and then we're finished all right so the
first thing we can do is we can measure
our distance from g
to our point x or whatever this point is
right so that's this distance here
and we can say okay that's our current
minimum distance
so at the moment g is the closest point
and its distance is this
right now we have to move up one step in
our in our thing so if g was g was down
here
right so we're going to move up to d
i put it in the wrong place this is why
you do it on a computer and not by hand
right so g is over here that's better so
we're at g this is we've got our current
distance we're going to move up to e so
we move up to e and we say well okay
could it be e well it's not because this
is the distance here right and that's
slightly further than this distance so
we don't include e
now you might think well the next thing
to do is to jump up to b and do the same
check again but it's not quite because
now we're at e we just have to make sure
there couldn't possibly be something
over this side if you consider right
this is a little bit it's a little bit
tricky to get your head around but this
is our current minimum distance but
we're only this little distance away
from this boundary so it is possible
that if there was a point the other side
it would be closer so we just have to
make sure there isn't first before we go
any further so we go down from e into
this point we look at this distance and
we realize that's that's no good so we
can ignore it and then we can return
back up to e so as you're going you go
down your tree right at the beginning
and then you work your way up and you
might visit a different node if there's
a chance there's something in there that
we haven't looked at yet
all right so we're back at e
we currently know that our closest point
is g we're going to go up to b now all
right now we look at b and b is not
any closer than g so it's not b
right so that's good do we need to check
inside b i guess so yeah well you guess
so but actually no because the distance
from this point to b
is this much and our minimum distance is
this much
so even if there was a point just beyond
the line it couldn't possibly be closer
than g right so we don't need to check
there all we have to do is compare the
distance to this line
from here and say okay it could be
nothing this side that could ever be
closer than this point we've already
found right so we don't need to look in
there so we can jump straight to a
completely discount that as being far
away and again we do our check this
distance to this line here is too far so
anything this side can't possibly be
closer than g
and we're done right and this is one of
the neat things actually about the kd
tree is if you're going to calculate
distances and thresholds and things and
what's bigger than something else in
many many dimensions that takes quite a
long time for every point comparison you
do but all the point comparisons we do
here are in whatever
um axes we happen to be in right now so
it's either x or y
and if there was if it was four or
three-dimensional it would be x or y or
z or w whatever you call your dimensions
right as we keep going on um
this is pretty quick maths right it's
just is this bigger than this or is this
greater than or equal to this pretty
straightforward and so this is really
quite quick and we've got what one two
one two i need to not count my x's one
two
fifteen points i drew them in i should
know fifteen points here so if we have
to search for fifteen points
um
to find what the closest point is we can
already see this is going to start to
get quite a bit faster because we've
gone one comparison two three and then a
couple on the way back up
five six points perhaps right depending
on my example and of course the more
points you have the better this will get
if you have a million points and you
divide it in two you're at five hundred
thousand two hundred fifty thousand
hundred and twenty five thousand and you
and within a few layers of your tree
you've already massively
shortened the search that you have to do
right you want to do the absolute
minimum number of point comparisons that
you can does this work for everything
does this work no so for
for point clouds it works really really
quite nicely um for graphics in terms of
sort of triangles and you know polygons
and and vertices and faces and stuff no
not really right and it doesn't work
because it's not clear how you then
start to split this stuff up it splits
very nicely on a point less so on a
triangle which has three points and a
face and is facing in a certain
direction and stuff like this this is
when you get into the slightly more
powerful data structures like the
bounding volume hierarchy which is what
underpins stuff like ray tracing
it's a logarithmic function
yeah it's log to base two so essentially
the deeper you get she's never a good
situation in some sense
it plateaus out
and i think mike's going to demonstrate
this in a second
is that
log4j is like milk it's like water it's
everywhere